رغم انسحاب روسيا من منظمه السياحه
العالميه لا تزال بلاد القياصره ملادا
سياحيا مهما في العالم نظرا للعمق
التاريخي والغنى الطبيعي وايضا المساحه
الجغرافيه الواسعه تنتمي روسيا الى مجموعه
الدول ذات الاجواء الشتويه القاسيه لكنها
رغم ذلك فانها تتمتع بريف مثالي ومدن
وحصون تاريخيه وقصور متلالئه فضلا عن
سياحه التسلق والتزلج على المرتفعات تمتلك
روسيا العديد من المدن الرائعه التي تعتبر
مسارات سياحيه فمثلا تتميز موسكو بميدانها
الاحمر والكرملين وقصره كذلك فان مدينه
سانتروسبورغ تعد من اكثر المدن جمالا في
فصل الشتاء وساحه القصر وايضا قصر بيتر
هوف لا تتوقف هناك السياحه عند هذه المدن
فلدينا مدينه كازان الشهيره وايضا مدينه
سوتشي حيث تتميز هذه المدن باج وائها
الشتويه الرائعه ما يجعلها مكانا هاما
لسياحه الشتاء
[موسيقى]